but i love what you're doing and you
have
i know that you're in town this is not
airing today but when we are talking to
you right now you're in town for the
netflix comedy festival yes i am and
were you at are we at the hollywood bowl
the other night no i was not at the
hollywood bowl i um i wish i was there i
i wasn't there and uh i heard about it
though yeah absolutely what are you
gonna do and then i did a show the next
night where everybody's show the next
night everyone who had chosen next night
had a wall of security of course because
of that but my show no security there
was the audience was standing there were
actually no seats some of the audience
was sitting on the stage i was like this
is good everyone else is secret service
security and they were like well chris i
mean you can defend yourself
because they look at you and they go
he's athletic yeah he can beat the [ __ ]
out of us he's so good looking we're not
going to slap that
do you are you did you worry did you
actually so the next night being there
and you obviously you are worried
because you said
there wasn't it weird that it's in your
hands in my head to be honest with me
you know why i was in my be honest with
you i'm gonna be honest with you to be
honest you know we're here too right
to be honest with me i feel sometimes i
feel like i'm just a schizophrenic and
none of this is real this is just one of
my other personalities i i thought the
reason why it scared me is because i
would rather
just
if dave chappelle or if something would
happen if somebody just got shot
not a big deal i don't mind getting shot
in the head it's over i don't want to
get stabbed that guy rushed the stage
with a bayonet
he had a like a colonial bayonet knife
to a gun i was like
can i say something i'm not going to
edit this out but i want to edit it out
because you're giving people ideas why
do you want to be shot well because you
wanted to be you yeah i just don't want
to get stabbed to death i'd rather get
if you're what if somebody came up with
a piece of loose leaf and gave you a
paper cut oh that would suck i no i'm
serious and they had a little wedge of
lemon what if they had a big piece of
paper they give you a little paper cut
and then they squeeze lemon on you and
you go get off the stage and somebody
comes up and takes the lemon away and
then your security comes up and rips his
shred with a shredder and takes his
paper away and shreds his paper well
that on for well here's the thing is
you want to do that you can do that but
the thing about me again we're all a
little quirky you cut you'd give me a
little paper cut and you squeeze lemon
in it i come that's the thing
is i'll just that's the only way i can
come
really yep you i have two kids
and that's how it happened look at a cop
so you would say come in the other room
she would she'd put out like little
sheets of loose leaf paper
and lemon yup and then she would just
slice your finger
that's it put the lemon on you come and
then she sat in a puddle and two little
girls two little beautiful girls so
listen you want to rush the stage on me
you have a poncho on
because that's what i'll do that's all
splooge so you think that a poncho is
the best way to protect yourself from
splooch you tell me
you said he said splooch splooge
wait my daughter's correcting the
splooge
splooge
and what did i say splooch
splooch i love that yeah that's why i
have the kids here yeah if the kid the
kids got to tell me the difference
between splooch and sploojin yes splooge
is i think l-o-o-g-e right but a splooch
is kissing a puddle of splooge see
splooch to me when i think of sploosh i
think of guy in a neighborhood like oh
it's jimmy splooch or you know brooklyn
like that guy's a splooch yeah see
splooge but splooge to me is the french
guy in the same neighborhood
france wants fluge francois spruce
[Music]
bye